uh my talk at the table is about
presidential leadership
president trump has been criticized for
not delivering a message of unity during
the national protests about racism in
this country
and this concept of leadership though is
one of many ways that the presidency has
evolved since george washington took the
oath of office
cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent john dickerson has
a new book it's called the hardest job
in the world
the american presidency he spoke with
four presidents as part of his research
including president trump
and john joins me now john good morning
um you know the book is full
of some of the best wit and wisdom over
the ages about the presidency and then
you add your own written wisdom to that
there's an fdr quote i think we can
begin with he says
i can only go as fast as the people will
let me
we're in a moment now where it seems
like the people want to go pretty
quickly
and in a very particular direction and
the president in a way is holding them
back
is that typical well yeah
well you know i said as you can imagine
i spent a lot of time investigating just
this question for the book
and and presidents kind of have to have
a very delicate ear to the public
sentiment they cannot get ahead of the
public no one wants to run up a hill and
have nobody behind them
on the other hand there are times when a
president frankly just has to run to the
front of the parade
and that's why most of the social
movements in america come from the
people
and it's the presidents who catch up and
so while the president doesn't want to
move too fast there is also a problem of
moving too slow
and getting that balance right that's
why fdr was so
great as a president lincoln has an
almost identical quote about public
sentiment
with it everything can be done without
public sentiment nothing can be done
and the question for president trump in
this current moment is
is he hearing the call from the country
and
is he responding in a way that is
commensurate with or equal to
the challenge of that call and little
response isn't enough
and the response has to hear the call
and answer it
yeah and then one more question about
the current occupant uh before we get on
to the job itself
divisiveness there are some hot button
issues that a president might shy away
from
this particular president president
trump seems to want to push buttons
is divisiveness has that always been a
hallmark of the office
well it divisive in the sense that
people have been unhappy with presidents
who are
uh who they think are doing the wrong
thing but
there is a stewardship duty of the job
to be the president of the whole country
and to speak when president trump
started his speech
at west point he said i come here on
behalf of the whole country
that's the president's job you're not
president of your base on the other hand
presidents are both the leader of their
party and the leader of the country
but it has traditionally been the job of
the president
to sew up the country when it breaks
apart and to do things to bring people
together and think about lincoln's uh
lincoln's address his second inaugural
address there were assassins in town
confederate assassins there to kill him
the war was still going on
and his message was let's forgive and
bind up our wounds
that is the tradition that presidents
have usually tried to meet that unity
tradition
well on the subject of forgiveness if
you are not currently a supporter of
president trump out there in tv land
you might want to give him a break
because as you write mr dickerson the
job has gotten particularly hard
i have a quote here the american
presidency is in trouble
it is overburdened misunderstood and
almost
impossible job to do how did it get that
way
well we just kept leaping and lumping
things on the president's lap it's
always been hard presidents
have complained about the job since it
existed what's new
now though and again what i was trying
to do in this book is go down to the
blueprint of the office go back to
basics what does the job mean
what do we expect from it and is it
right to expect those things we've added
things on to the presidency certainly in
the national security realm
it's gotten more complex it's always
been a difficult job but it's gotten
more complex threats are now
nuclear cyber terrorism pandemics
on the economy because we're all
interconnected the president has to act
as an emergency responder on the economy
in a way previous presidents have it and
then because congress is having uh
is no longer a co-equal branch is sort
of the little brother trying to keep
up it puts more things on the
president's to-do list while robbing him
of a governing partner
in congress and then we have the
partisanship there's nothing wrong with
partisanship
the partisanship of the kind we have now
is awful because
it locks everything up and freezes
everything as opposed to being the
useful
fighting that's a part of government and
so all of those forces
plus social medias and we end up having
our public debates hijacked by
bad faith partisans as opposed to people
who are acting in the public good
all of those things have lumped together
to make a hard job
even harder yeah it's a wonderful volume
the product of
more than a decade of work on your part
a career covering politics and i should
point out to people that it's not just a
history of the american presidency
but a a guidebook for voters now less
than 150 days away
from picking the next occupant of the
oval office so an important volume on
two fronts mr dickerson thank you very
much the book the hardest job in the
world
goes on sale tomorrow